françoise hardy ça va bien je parle de
tours de chant cependant puisque depuis
quelques temps c'est votre rentrée oui
enfin bien moi vient très peu de temps
alors on peut en tout cas jugé sur les
premières fois contient les premières
fois ôtés agréable j'espère que ça va
continuer comme c'est important quand
même oui bien sûr vous chantez combien
de chansons sur scène vous combien sont
vous en tant qu'auteur compositeur
je ne sais pas j'ai pas fort et que je
compte maintenant pris que de prendre
pas mal de temps jeu permettant la
moitié est depuis quelques temps vous
fait appel quand même à des compositeurs
comme part à mon amie la rose comme le
géant semble toujours faire appel à
d'autres
l'auteur un autre compositeur préféré je
préfère parce que moi je fais toujours
le même style de chanson alors ça
risquerait de tomber un peu dans la
monotonie si je faisais pas appel
d'autres gens quand vous avez débuté
parce que cette fille linda pour réussir
en disant voilà j'en donne trois ans
qu'un nom produits tous plus du tout
mais toute façon le monde la seule chose
que j'ambitionne s était de nos
registres in disque est vraiment
joaillier pas plus loin moyenne pour moi
c'était le bout du monde
de pouvoir enregistrer nice et
maintenant on voit maintenant je vis au
jour le chauffe
j'attends de voir ce qui va se passer
j'ai pas énormément d'ambition de talent
tort bien et dans la vie quelles sont
vos ambitions en menant la vie c'est
d'être heureuse et parents trop de gens
malheureux mais vous y arrivez
la première chose oui la deuxième c'est
à dire la deuxième les gens donc j'aime
tant parler de ça aujourd'hui françoise
où nous recevez pas chez vous mais ils
ont presque dans un studio un studio
taux de gras et ce studio appartient à
jean marie périer c'est cela oui et
d'ailleurs je crois que puisque jean
marie est là maintenant il paraît que
vous fait vos débuts en tant que
réalisateur puisque le vieil un show qui
va se alors pour thème françoise pour
des fêtes de noël je crois c'est vous
qui l'avez réalisés n'ont laissé gérard
si j'ai fait que participer à la
réalisation
j'ai filmé quelques chansons mais
françois comment est il comme
réalisateur jean marie périer très bien
très bien on verra où est-ce que ça
s'est passé a été tournée alors c'est
pour ça que c'était dur
c'est à dire parce qu'on ait aucune
permission de tourner il paraît qu'ils
avaient détourné 11 chansons en cinq
jours ce qui est pas beaucoup je
prendrai ce qu'on m'a dit vous êtes
photographe de métier
oui et maintenant la réalisation bouton
télévision françois de la ville et roche
de cette émission
oui qu'est ce que ça donne eh bien les
chansons que jean marc hia fumée
entièrement comme il voulait parfait
donc rendez vous en décembre ce moment
là